today on the matt walsh show a day after
a serial felon and career criminal mowed
down dozens of people at a christmas
parade democrats are out in public
calling for more criminals to be
released into our communities meanwhile
the killer was a blm supporter
apparently and apparently a racist who
carried out his attack an hour from
kenosha two days after the written house
verdict will we ever be told the truth
about his motives and new york goes
nuclear in the war on history taking
down a 200 year old thomas jefferson
statue and removing a theodore roosevelt
statue from a museum you have to hear
the reason they gave for this decision
it's almost impossible to believe plus
kyle rittenhouse talks to tucker carlson
condoleezza rice calls for more female
coaches in the nfl and joe biden claims
that there's an epidemic of anti-trans
hate crimes is that true no it isn't but
we'll discuss that and more today on the
matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well black friday is coming up and it's
one of the biggest shopping days of the
year obviously but that also means it's
one of the biggest opportunities for
scammers some of the most common scams
include buying a gift online that never
arrives sellers demanding payments with
gift cards fake shopping websites and
fake delivery notifications these are
all things that you potentially
encounter
when you're online on black friday so
it's important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft are affecting
our lives every day we put our
information at risk on the internet in
an instant a cyber criminal could steal
what's yours sometimes even harm your
finances your credit your reputation all
of that is on the line potentially
that's why it's so good that there's
lifelock lifelock helps detect a wide
range of identity threats uh things that
you might not even think about or you
would never think to check or wouldn't
be able to check like your social
security number being for sale on the
dark web if they detect your information
has potentially been compromised they'll
send you an alert if god forbid
something does happen they have identity
theft or identity restoration specialist
on staff that can help you there as well
so look nobody can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can help protect
what's yours with lifelock by norton
join now and save up to 25 percent off
your first year by going to
lifeblock.com walsh that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 percent off
say what you want about the democrats
and there's plenty you can say almost
all of it bad but at least they always
stay on message and i mean always
and that didn't change yesterday after
the massacre in wakesha were a serial
felon career criminal previously
convicted of crimes ranging from bail
jumping to child rape domestic abuse and
so on currently out on what the d.a now
admits was inappropriately low bail
plowed his car intentionally into a
christmas parade and murdered five
people seriously injuring uh more many
more including including children and
yet in spite of this event or maybe
because of it
representative alexandria case or cortez
thought that yesterday of all days would
be the best and most appropriate time to
send a letter to five district attorneys
in new york criticizing quote excessive
bail
she tweeted yesterday
quote today we sent a letter with
representative maloney and
representative raskin to new york city's
five district attorneys requesting
information on excessive bail in new
york city in in the new york city court
system when prosecutors seek excessive
cash bail it results in increased rates
of incarceration particularly for
low-income defendants more than 75
percent of individuals in custody
haven't been convicted of a crime and
are confined in unsafe conditions
simply because they cannot afford cash
bail condemning thousands of individuals
to languish in such environments as they
await trial is unacceptable
well what's better miss cortes that they
languish in jail or that they plow
through a christmas parade
and run over a bunch of small children
which outcome is more acceptable to you
on balance
don't answer that
what's more important to protect the
physical safety of innocent civilians or
to cater to the emotional needs of
violent criminals
we'll get back to that question in a
moment but first
here's something from aoc's fellow squad
goblin rashida talib she did an
interview in axios this week where she
talked about her plan to release all of
the inmates from federal prison all of
them not a joke that's a thing she
actually actually wants to do
let's listen to that
in 2020 you endorsed
the breathe act which is a series of
proposals to transform america's
criminal justice system
and create quote a road map for prison
abolition
the breathe act proposes emptying
federal detention facilities within 10
years
to what extent have you wrestled with
any potential downsides of releasing
into society every single person who's
currently in a federal prison yeah
again i think that everyone's like oh my
god we're going to just release
everybody that's not what i'm saying
yeah but did you see how many people are
mentally ill that are in prison right
now no i know but the act that you so
actually says release everyone but in
ten years but think about it who will
release it if they were like human
traffickers oh i know child sex so
people say do you mean that you don't
actually support that because you
endorse them no i endorse the breathe
act in looking at federal
the policies and how we incarcerate
absolutely but it says
you cannot you cannot you cannot just
blankly say oh look she wants that's not
what i'm saying but that's like in plain
text
there are human traffickers oh i know
just silly human traffickers i mean come
on who have they ever hurt
notice something in order to defend her
plan to release violent criminals from
federal prison she assures us that most
of them are also crazy
this is a defense of the plan
this is supposed to make us feel better
hey don't worry about the psychopathic
child rapist and murderer moving in next
door he's just crazy
okay sleep tight
this breathak monstrosity by the way not
only abolishes federal prisons and
dumps its contents back into society but
also abolishes the death penalty of
course and abolishes life sentences
there'd be no more life sentences
that would mean that no matter what a
person does no matter what crime they
commit
they would be guaranteed to end up back
in our communities after marinating in a
stew with other violent felons for
several years or decades
now you may take solace in the fact that
we're perhaps a little ways away from
the point where a bill like this can
actually be passed
but if you want to know what it will
look like when we get there
you need to only look towards the
democrat-run cities across the country
they are the petri dish the laboratory
where democratic social experiments are
conducted
if you live in one of these cities then
you are part of a vast human
experiment
um and you are a test subject in that
experiment
the result is you know 50 people run
over in wisconsin
a skyrocketing street street violence
all across the country organized flash
gangs of looters emptying department
store shelves in places like san
francisco
this is the democratic vision their
utopian ideal
it should be clear by now and should
have been clear long ago that the push
for criminal justice reform is not
fueled by
compassion
even a misguided compassion
because compassion literally means
co-suffering
co-passion to suffer alongside someone
else
when you have compassion for someone
you take on their suffering to help
alleviate you help carry their cross
but the people who send violent
criminals into our neighborhoods
they have quite clearly
no concern for human suffering at all
their goals are ideological and
political and for them the political
outweighs everything all other concerns
are outweighed by the political
and they're willing to let countless
people suffer and die
countless innocents fall prey to
violence in order to achieve their
political and ideological ends
it is in every way the opposite of
compassion
if you're truly compassionate
and it's a good thing to be
compassionate
that is you're truly concerned with
alleviating human suffering
and that's what a that's what a
compassionate person is worried about
then the sort of criminal justice reform
you would advocate is the sort that puts
more violent criminals in prison and
keeps them there for longer
that's the reform we need
as is painfully obvious by now that's
what republicans should be advocating
for
i'm not interested in any republican who
who jumps on board the criminal justice
reform bandwagon at least criminal
justice reform as it is as it is seen by
the left
who adopts the leftist view
of the sort of reform we need in the
criminal justice system
and there are a lot of republicans who
have jumped on that bandwagon to include
donald trump
now the reform we need is that we're
gonna we're gonna take
violent dangerous people
and put them in a cage
away from the innocent people away from
our children and our wives
and keep them there
for a long time if not forever
but getting back to the specific case in
wakashia we know why the assailant daryl
brooks was on the street
we know that you know he should not have
been there
but there's still a question of why he
did what he did
the narrative from the media is that
brooks was fleeing the scene of another
crime but police held a press conference
yesterday where they clarified
that he was not being pursued he was not
actively fleeing anything
listen to that
at 4 39 pm on sunday november 21st of
2021 a lone subject
intentionally drove his maroon suv
through barricades into crowded people
that was celebrating the waukesha
christmas parade
which resulted in killing five
individuals
and injuring 48
additional individuals
i just received information that
two of the 48 are children and they're
in critical condition
we have information that the suspect
prior to the incident was involved in a
domestic disturbance
which was just minutes prior
and the suspect left that scene just
prior to our arrival
to that domestic disturbance
when
the suspect was driving through into the
crowd
one officer did discharge his fire arm
and fire shots at the suspect to stop
the threat
but due to the amount of people had to
stop
and
stop and fire noah did not fire any
other additional shots
the officer is on administrative leave
as part of a department protocol no one
was injured as a result of the officer
firing uh his discharge in his fire
weapon
firearm the subject was taken into
custody a short distance from the scene
and we are confident he acted alone
there's no evidence that this is a
terrorist incident
no evidence of a terrorist incident so
it was intentional obviously
he wasn't fleeing from anything which
was also obvious
i said that yesterday before the police
officer
there confirmed it now clearly this was
not someone who was trying to evade the
police by
driving through a parade okay that's not
what you do when you're trying to escape
the
cops and yet they can still declare less
than 24 hours after the attack that it
wasn't politically or racially motivated
how
isn't the attack itself evidence of a
terrorist attack
i mean what's the evidence of a
terrorist attack i don't know the attack
he drove through a parade the fact that
he intentionally plowed his car into a
parade and killed and injured dozens of
people isn't that at least evidence
of a terrorist attack
we also know that brooks had expressed
anti-white and pro-blm views on his
social media pages apparently and in his
rap songs
we know that this attack was carried out
less than an hour from kenosha two days
after the not guilty verdict
not only is there evidence of a racially
and politically motivated terrorist
attack here but that is the most
reasonable assumption at this point
and assumptions may be all we ever have
as i said yesterday this story will be
stuffed down the memory hole just like
las vegas and that's already happening
because every aspect of this event no
matter the reason no matter the motive
every aspect of this event is toxic to
the democrat narrative
the only thing that makes it difficult
for them
to really memory hole this thing is that
brooks is still alive
perhaps that will change too who knows
but we can be sure about one thing
they will never tell us the full truth
about this ever
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
if you don't already have one now is the
time to get a reliable vpn
like expressvpn that's the top one
that's the one to go with using the
internet without expressvpn it's like
having a first aid kit but not keeping
it stocked up i mean
most of the time you'll probably be fine
but what if you suddenly get in trouble
and you need it then you're gonna wish
you had it by then it's too late right
so get expressvpn now every time you
connect to an unencrypted network cafes
hotels airports any hacker on the same
network can gain access to your personal
data
passwords financial details etc doesn't
take much technical knowledge to hack
someone just some cheap hardware is
needed and like a smart 12 year old
could do it your data is valuable
hackers can make up to a thousand
dollars per person selling personal
information on the dark web um why use
expressvpn well because you get an
encrypted tunnel it creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet hackers are not able to
steal your sensitive data and also it's
very secure um it'd take a hacker with a
super computer over a billion years to
get past expressvpn's encryption that's
how secure it is so secure your online
data today by visiting
expressvpn.comwalsh that's
expressvpn.comwalsh
and you can get an extra three months
for free expressvpn.com
walsh
uh
all right i'm still uh you know i i i
think i've shared with you before
and it's hard for me to be uh vulnerable
but i hope you appreciate that that at
times i can be um i can be vulnerable
and i can reveal things about myself
that are difficult to reveal so so for
example look i i don't like spiders
i don't okay i fear nothing in life
except spiders that's the only thing
um
and you know maybe maybe 10 or 15 other
things but mainly spiders i just you
know i
to me they they look like
it's hard for me to even
come to terms with the fact that a
loving god would create spiders to me
they look like
beasts that escaped from hell at some
point during creation i'm not i'm not
proposing that it's not an actual
theological theory on my part but that's
how they seem to me anyway
so we have a you know like a an
infestation in our basement of um of
wolf spiders
and so uh two nights ago we went down
there into like the basement into like
the creepiest part of the basement where
the spiders always are and we had some
my wife and i were putting some traps
down to catch the spiders and then my
wife thought it'd be really funny um
while i was laying a [ __ ] down to run
out of the basement and uh turn the
light off and then shut the door so that
i was in pitch black surrounded by
the wolf spiders that is not
funny at all here's the thing
and i i maintained my composure and it
was okay she thought it was hilarious
this is the double standard that we
understand as men
because here's what i know
i could never do that if i had ever done
anything like that
as a man
this it would not be funny we'd be in
marriage counseling for it so
but you understand that that's that's
one of those as a when you're married
you you come to accept certain basic
double standards you just have to and i
think this is probably one of them
all right so i want to start with this
just a quick update um
we've chronicled the fight over my event
at uh slu st louis university which is
supposed to be on december 1st and they
had the petition they were trying to
stop me from coming
and the administration they were pulling
all these little dirty tricks behind the
scene to try to you know all these
things because they didn't want me to
come and um
i did receive word yesterday that the
event will go forward as planned so if
you live anywhere near st louis and you
want to come on december 1st and see the
event you can um you know they had their
petition i had mine we got up to about
twenty thousand i've shut the petition
down now we got to almost 20 000
signatures
and i've declared victory because the
event will happen here's what it comes
down to
never get into into a petition war
with the guy who raised a hundred grand
for abuela
or who changed addresses so that i could
speak at a school board meeting in
virginia just don't don't do that
and the thing is even
it's probably for the best and maybe the
university realized this
that you just let me do the event
because if you'd shut it down i would
have showed up there with a bullhorn
okay here's what you have to understand
about me i am very petty
and extremely annoying i know that about
myself
and it's it's so it's best to just not
do this leave my vets events alone this
is this is for for all future schools
it's not worth it
you're just bringing more attention to
me
i like the attention
i get even i become even more
insufferable when you do that best thing
is just let me do the event leave it
alone i'll come and do it and that'll be
it
all right good
um
next this is from the daily wire it says
and you you just have to listen to this
story to
as i said it's almost unbelievable some
aspects of this story
okay a statue of president theodore
roosevelt
will be relocated from the front of the
american museum of natural history
this is in new york where it stood for
more than 80 years the theodore
roosevelt presidential library
foundation announced in a press release
friday
that the statue of pr the president
naturalist and founder of the national
park service will be moved to
roosevelt's presidential library which
is set to open in 2026.
um
it says this is from the statement it
reads the theodore roosevelt
presidential library today announced
that it has entered into an agreement
with the city of new york for the long
long-term loan and reconsideration of
the equestrian statute designed by james
earl frazier which was commissioned by
the board of trustees of the new york
state roosevelt memorial in 1929.
the statement then explained that the
reason for the relocation was because
the statute was problematic
and then and listen to this
okay the board of tr uh library believes
the equestrian statue is problematic in
its composition
moreover
its current location denies passers-by
consent and context
the agreement with the city allows the
tr library to relocate the statute for
storage while considering a display
that would enable it to serve as an
important tool to study our nation's
past
okay the statue
does not get consent it's problematic
why is it problematic well because
um it's a uh theodore roosevelt is on a
is on a well they never i've actually
read three articles
about them moving this statue
so i could
maybe get a more fleshed out argument
for what makes it problematic but all
i've seen is just it's problematic
and we're left to guess what's
problematic about it and i guess it's
because theodore roosevelt is on a is on
a it's an equestrian statue so he's on a
horse in the statue and he is flanked by
two uh by a native american man and an
african man
who are walking alongside him and pretty
clearly there they are you know guides
as he is because he was an explorer
among his many um accolades and titles
and so and and so it's pretty clear
that's that's the context of the statue
why is that problematic i mean it's a
historical depiction of a thing that
really happened
a native american guide that they
native americans were excellent guides
why is that is that an insult are we not
supposed to acknowledge that anymore
but
gets consent let's can we can we hone in
on that for just a moment
the statue
does not get consent it has the statue
has violated the consent of the people
passing by it
how exactly would a statue go about
obtaining consent
so you can here's what we're being told
now in new york
you can have your consent violated by an
inanimate object
this is what like a form of is this is
like a form of sexual assault that the
statue is uh
is guilty of
because the statute didn't get con the
statute did not get consent from you
before it decided to exist
if you come across an object that you
don't want to see then your consent is
violated
my god
this the phrase beyond parody doesn't
even begin to cover this i mean
we could say this is like something out
of the babylon be but it's it's worse
than that i mean a year ago if the
babylon bee
had had put out a headline about how a
statue was being taken down because it
violated consent
we
i probably wouldn't have laughed at it
because i would have said well that's a
little bit too you know that's that's a
little that you know that's not very
realistic in order to be successful
satire or parody it has to be it has to
be some some realism to it right that's
what makes it funny
i probably would have said well that's
uh that's a little too far out of left
field
truly stranger than fiction we can say
now and i'm still wondering how does a
statue get consent
and which statues need to obtain consent
and why just statues i mean why not all
objects
there are a great many objects
that i'm forced to see that i find quite
hideous and upsetting
every city in america that you go to now
they've got these
these uh the modern art if i can even
call them art monstrosities just mangled
jumbles of metal
placed in the middle of the town square
and i gotta walk by that i'm extremely
annoyed
i i find it even nauseating in some way
and slightly disturbing
i never get consent no no one consulted
me the statue didn't consult me
so maybe we need to post like signs
every five feet for 10 miles leading up
to the statue
warning that the statue was coming
and then and then more signs like every
every uh
five feet for the next 10 miles after
you passed by the statue
with information for like counselors in
case you were traumatized by what you
just saw is that what we need
my god in heaven
and and also this is in a museum right
so remember what we've been told
is that um
[Music]
is that well we no this is not a war on
history we're taking out all these
monuments and statues and we're just
we're moving them to museums
well now the museums are getting rid of
them too
and now it's being sent to the uh
theodore roosevelt library which by the
way is not built yet
and will be in north dakota
where like five people and a moose will
see it
and the theodore roosevelt library has
said they're probably gonna change the
statue
they're gonna make some alterations
potentially to the statue before they
put it on display for nobody to see in
north dakota
oh but it's not a war on history right
there's no slippery slope here
meanwhile this is also in new york
same day
it says uh
thomas jefferson new york post says
thomas jefferson is no longer in the
room where it happens art handlers
packed up an 884 pound statue of
jefferson in a wooden crate monday after
a mayoral commission voted to banish the
likeness of the nation's third president
from city hall where it's resided for
nearly two centuries
because he owned slaves about a dozen
workers with marshall uh fine arts spent
several hours
carefully removing the painted plaster
monument from its pedestal inside the
city council chamber and surrounding it
with sections of foam and wooden boards
um where is he going he is going to
uh he'll be on a long-term loan to the
new york historical society which plans
to have
jefferson's model survive in its lobby
and reading room
no we're just moving the statues to a
museum oh no now we're just moving them
to a historical society oh now we're
just moving them to storage oh no now
we're just moving them to a dumpster
but the dumpster will make sure that
they're that they're respected there
you know
uh this is one
well i always say i hate to say i told
you so but we know that's not true so
i'll skip over that that lie
i did tell you so on this i wasn't the
only one a few of us did
and just a few
i mean i've been warning about this you
can go
fact check me on google if you want four
five six years i've been writing about
this
about how it was going to ha it was
gonna we were gonna get to this point
this is where we were headed
the moment they started tearing down the
confederate statues this was inevitable
and you know now of course you can say
that and everybody at least on the right
will agree with you
but four years ago five years ago
when they were getting rid of uh you
know of the stonewall jackson and robert
e lee
um
monuments
if you had made that argument that hey
this is a war on american history and
they're gonna come for the founders next
if you when you made that argument four
or five years ago you had a great many
people certainly everybody on the left
and even a lot of people on the right
would attack you
and say this is a slippery slope fallacy
it's not going to happen it's not the
same thing how dare you draw a
comparison
well not to relive ancient history now
but
maybe it might be worthwhile to explain
like how did i know
five years ago
that it would get to this point
um it's not because i have a crystal
ball and it wasn't a lucky guess either
so there's there's two things one is
precedent
okay so
all i had to do was
listen to what the people who were
advocating tearing down the confederate
monuments
what reasons were they giving
and the reasons were these are these are
the two reasons
they were traitors
and they supported slavery
now there might be other reasons that
you could potentially come up with to
get rid of some of these statues but
those were not the reasons
that the people doing it
were were providing
for them it was they were traders and
they were they supported slavery
well it should be really obvious that oh
hold on a second traders to their
government
you know and uh and supported slavery
well the founding fathers
same thing
not exactly the same situation
different situation the revolutionary
war is not the same as the civil war but
they they own slaves so they supported
slavery and
they were traitors to the crown if they
had if they had lost if they had been
the
losers in the revolutionary war they
would have been hung as traders and
remembered that way by history
and that's all that's the precedent
now you can get into the nuances and
draw distinctions and there's plenty of
nuanced distinctions you can make
um to differentiate thomas jefferson
from robert e lee
but those two basic things apply to both
and so it wasn't hard to connect the
dots and say well if this is the reason
they're giving
then here we go
and really we could put the traitor
thing aside because that's that's that's
was was really you know as a secondary
complaint about the people from the
people tearing down the confederate
statues really was all about slavery
right
and well if if that's it
then everybody's coming down
and if it's not just slavery but racism
in general
then then every almost everyone in
history
who was born prior to you know about 40
years ago or 30 years ago
none of them passed that litmus test
because they're all racist by our
standards today
and if they lived in the 19th century or
prior to that
very good chance they supported slavery
if they lived in the
16th century or prior to that almost
certainly they supported slavery
um
so that's how we knew
and also the second thing is that the
people who were carrying out this
campaign to tear down the confederate
statues and now the founders and
everybody else and and theodore
roosevelt
and abraham lincoln monuments have also
come under attack and his name has been
you know they're considering taking his
name name off of various buildings
school and school buildings and
everything
the other thing is that we could we
could look at this mob and and see
that
these are not just people who are
passionate about civil war history
okay these are people who have a a beef
against america itself against american
history
which is why i always said from the very
beginning when it came to the
confederate statues
even if you
could see an argument for getting rid of
some of these confederate statues
you still should not be joining hands
with this
mob your message should be your response
should be hey
some of these statues maybe there's an
argument for taking them down but not
right now
and not like this
this this is not how we make these kinds
of decisions
it is never a good sign when mobs of
people are going around the country
tearing down
century-old monuments
that never leads to anything good
all right next um
kyle ridden house's defense attorney was
on fox yesterday and had some thoughts
about what kyle should do um now that
he's free and i'm not sure that i
totally agree let's listen
yeah my advice would be to change his
name and start his life over
um he's very recognizable right now
there's a lot of people who i don't
think um
have his best interests at heart
uh and probably want to make him a
symbol of something i don't think he
wants to be
necessarily
um associated with
and once you give up
your name and your likeness
and you be
joining those causes
i think a lot of people will use you for
their own purposes and you won't be able
to control it
well
uh
giving my two cents not that my two
cents really matters or or the or the
you know the thoughts of mark richards
his defense attorney it doesn't really
matter i mean kyle rittenhouse will do
what what he thinks is right for his own
life but
i i will say that uh i personally
disagree i think you've you know i mean
change your name
and and and go and go away and hide
he didn't do anything wrong that's
what's up that's what a guilty person
does
that's what someone who's done something
shameful
you know that that's what you do
that's like a if you're a sex offender
and one once you're off the registry
which you really never should be offered
but once you're off of the registry
maybe you try to change your name or
something or
go away in shame um that's not kyle
rittenhouse he hasn't done anything
wrong he's been wronged
and so my advice would be
very much from the uh approach from the
other end here
fight for your name
fight to clear your
name do do what is right for you in your
own life but
if it were me that's what i would do
you know
change your name and
slink away into obscurity
if that's what you think will bring you
the most peace and joy in your life then
go ahead and do it there's not anything
morally wrong with that i'm not saying
that but
you know the the people who have um
the fact that your name
is now associated with murder and racism
that's not because of you it's not
anything you did wrong
and so i would i would fight for it
another interesting tidbit
kyle rittenhouse was interviewed by
tucker carlson and big shocker here he
says that lynn wood is apparently a con
artist who would have guessed
how long were you there i was in jail
for 87 days and
this goes this follows in with lynn wood
who
lynn wood
was raising money on my behalf and he
held me in jail for 87 days disrespected
my wishes put me on media interviews
which i should never have done which he
said oh you're going to go talk to the
washington post which was not a good
idea along with john pierce they said i
was safer in jail
and set up at home with my family and
then after i'm built your lawyer said
that my lawyer said that john pierce and
lynn wood
87 days is a long time to be in jail
it was
it was very long i lost a lot of weight
in there i i since then gained it back
i know the feeling yeah
but 87 days of
not being with my family for defending
myself and being taken advantage to
being used for a cause by these
by john pierce and lynnwood
trying to solicit not solicit trying to
raise money so they can take it for
their own benefit not trying to set me
free
so
you think they could have raised the
money for bail faster but they didn't
um i believe it
i believe sometime in september
september 5th i want to say
they had over a million dollars and bail
was set and able to be posted in
september so they could have had me sign
the waiver for extradition and had me
back in wisconsin and i could have been
bailed out
by mid-september but they wanted to keep
me in jail until november 20th
he's a really impressive kid by the way
i watched the interview and i was very
impressed with him
really composed and poised
um
which is
tremendous given given what he's what
he's been through i mean most most
people in general
takes you know
sitting on camera in that kind of
environment even talking to someone
who's friendly to you
it's hard to come off
well uh but especially given everything
he's been through i was very impressed
with that
as far as linwood goes may i have to say
i i was somewhat amazed at this time
last year
when i got on this show and on twitter
and i criticized lynnwood um when he was
pushing all that kraken stuff with
sydney powell and
you know they're going to release the
kraken and uh
church it's it's going to be the thing
that breaks the case wide open and and
trump will be reinstated as president
biden will will never be president they
were promising that
and as long as we give them money like
lynn wood and sydney powell now we give
them personally we give them money and
uh and we'll never be told exactly what
they're doing with the money or how
that's going to help anything but um as
long as we do that then everything will
be fine
and i said at the time that the guy
linwood is a con artist and a sleazy
snake oil salesman
and just a slime ball
and really pretty obvious that he's all
of those things and lots of people uh on
you know watch the show criticize me
on twitter it attacked me really angrily
this is one thing we've got to be better
about on the right i think
we can't fall for con artists like this
we just got to be smarter than that
there shouldn't be any lin woods on the
right
um we shouldn't allow that
and it's embarrassing it really is
because you see these guys and you think
well he's such an obvious grifter
how could anyone fall for it but then
you remember
that con artists don't need to fool
everybody
or even most people or even even most of
the minority of people
they only need they only need to fool
some people and fool them hard right
it's like the whatever the nigerian
prince scammers and all those really
obvious email scams that you get
they don't need even five percent of the
people who take the email who get the
email to take it seriously
they just need a relative handful and
those people they take for all their
worth
that's how cults work also same
principle
and you find that that some people have
something in them
a certain part of their brain
and sometimes it's it's hard to figure
out because some of the people that go
again back a year ago
some of the people that i talked to
about lynn wood
and and were
totally buying into it
and saw him as like the savior of the
republic i remember talking to people
and having them say that to my face look
me in the eyes
and call him literally a savior
and these people are not stupid they're
smart people some of them
smarter than me which is not hard to do
so what is it exactly and i think if i
were to find the most generous
interpretation
i think some people have a sort of
overactive sense of loyalty
and
these con artists know how to tap into
that
cult leaders know how to tap into that
they know how to exploit that over
developed loyalty instinct that some
people have even some smart people
meanwhile they themselves have no
loyalty instinct at all so they're loyal
to no one
they have no honor
no integrity they don't care about
anybody but themselves
and they're exploiting those who are too
easily loyal
too eager to be loyal
so i think that's um
part of what it is maybe i'm just
jealous too because as you know i'm an
aspiring cult leader
uh with the sweet baby gang but one
thing i know is that my sweet babies
they would never
they would never have for me you know
they would never let me get away with
the kinds of things that lynnwood gets
away with i know that
when i step out of line even the sweet
babies will call me on it in a
heartbeat and i have to begrudgingly
appreciate that
okay next we got condoleezza rice she
made an appearance on
monday football with these broadcasts
that now eli manning and peyton manning
do
and she talked about the need to get
more women involved in football and you
can only imagine
how i might feel about that but let's
listen
condi women have made great strides in
the nfl in the past years there's 12
female coaches in the nfl just talk
about
one of the next steps for women in the
nfl you've been very outspoken over the
years about the need for more movement
for women in the nfl
well i'm really glad to see women in the
front offices that makes a big
difference by the way in the front
office of the nfl as well and then uh
women on the field as officials
that's a wonderful breakthrough and uh
increasingly
on coaching staffs i think the next
breakthrough is uh to see if women can
find their way into say position coaches
uh because if you're a position coach
you've got a shot then at uh coordinator
i've never thought
that you're just going to put a woman in
there you're gonna have to have somebody
who goes through that progression but
i'm really proud of what the women in
the nfl are doing
it's high time because you do not have
to have played this game necessary with
all due respect to present company
to to understand it and i think to to
coach it well
um yeah it's high time to have women
coaches in the nfl why exactly like what
what what problem does that solve to put
women on the sidelines nfl as football
coaches
no we don't need women as football
coaches uh we we don't come on
here's here's the thing and condoleezza
rice is correct
that you don't need you don't
necessarily need to have played the game
to be a coach
and there are plenty of great players
who have made really lousy coaches so
just because you know how to play a
position doesn't mean that you know how
to coach it
just because you
you know are an expert in a certain
field doesn't necessarily mean that
you're going to be a good teacher
so we we know about that
it's kind of a different skill set
fine you don't need to be to have played
it okay
but what qualities
do you need in order to be a football
coach
and yeah you need knowledge of the game
it helps to have played it to have to
have that first-hand knowledge
but you also need to be as a football
coach you need to be a leader of men
okay football coaches are the good ones
anyway are leaders of men
and uh women are not leaders of men
that's not to say they can't be leaders
but a woman is not going to be the most
effective leader of a group of young men
now if you've got in a different
environment like a teacher in a in a in
a school room in a classroom
is also a leader the good ones are
leaders
there's lots of great uh female teachers
obviously
but in a football environment where it's
all men
you need men to be leaders of those men
especially because you're going out onto
the sort of metaphorical battlefield and
and you know it's all a game anyways
doesn't really matter in the end it's
not actual battle but it is it's a
physically demanding taxing thing you're
putting your you're putting your your
physical safety on the line and
everything else and that's why it's so
important to be leader to have coaches
that are good leaders of men and yeah
you need to be a man to do that
why is that well because
you know 95 percent of leadership is not
it's not
doesn't happen
through speaking
there's only about five percent
that
involves lecturing and speaking and
telling and saying things and coming up
with good lessons and everything like
that
and yeah men and women both can do that
but most 95 percent of leadership
is done through example
you are modeling
so if you want to be a leader of men you
have to model
uh for young men
you have to show them the path by
walking it yourself
and
men cannot look to women
to find out how to be good men just like
women can't look to men to find that out
about women
about themselves
all these things should be pretty
obvious but
i'm sure media matters will have some
fun with that one okay one other quick
thing um
don't have a lot of time for this but
this is i just wanted to mention this
this is from pink news of course one of
my favorite media outlets
it says us president joe biden honored
the dozens of trans people lost to a
horrifying wave of violence on
transgender day of remembrance
on saturday the world grew silent as
countless memorialized and celebrated
the lives of victims of anti-trans
violence
among them was biden who in a white
house news release paid tribute to those
we lost in the deadliest year on record
for transgender americans
the
the white house later hosted a vigil in
recognition of trans non-binary and
gender non-conforming people lost to
violence
with second gentleman doug imhoff
leading the ceremony
but seemingly capturing the extent of
the climate of fear felt by trans
americans biden's address was out of
date mere moments after it was published
it says uh this is biden he said quote
this year at least 46 transgender
individuals in this country were killed
in horrifying acts of violence
and then it goes on to say that actually
the death toll now is 48.
okay
so it's the deadliest year on record for
trans people
so deadly that the president united
states needs to hold a vigil for them
how many trans people have been murdered
48
the entire year up till now in the whole
country
now all murders are very sad
but but
what what do we expect exactly do we
expect the the trans murder rate to be
zero
ev all people
no matter what group you belong to
no matter what your gender identity is
you are susceptible to potentially being
murdered unfortunately because you're a
mortal human being and so you take any
random group of we could take plumbers
let's just take plumbers or you know how
many plumbers have been murdered this
year
probably not zero
does that automatically mean that
there's some sort of
anti-plumber hate crime epidemic
no what we find is that actually
the trans murder rate is very very low
it is significantly lower it's like a
third of the murder rate of the general
population
okay so i say that again if you're a
trans person statistically you are
much less likely to be murdered than if
you are a non-trans person
and then if you look at the at the
individual cases because you'll notice
something
when we're told about the trans uh you
know hate crime epidemic supposedly
um
they're always very vague about it
they say 48 trans people have been
murdered and those are all of the
murders
and they sort of vaguely say oh hate and
discrimination
but then if you ask well
you know can you give me some examples
of like are you saying that there are
people out there hunting trans people
and murdering them for being trans
can you give me some examples of that is
that all 48 of them
that's when they go silent because in
reality when you actually look at the
individual cases as i have done
and others have done
uh sohrabham amari has an article about
it today i think in the new york post
the federalist has done some research
into this when you look at the
individual cases you discover
that
in almost every case when a trans person
is murdered it's because it's drug
related it's gang related it's
prostitution related
um or it's related or it's related to
domestic violence
in other words it's it's the same reason
why most people are murdered
the same kind of risk categories apply
to trans people as applies to the
general population
anti-trans hatred or bigotry has nothing
to do with almost any of it
and yet they still talk about the trans
hate crime epidemic which is a total
fabrication it's a fantasy it doesn't
exist for the record
all right now time for the comment
section
do you know their name
all right uh before we get to some of
the comments here
if we mentioned yesterday we've launched
this uh merchandise store the merch
store
on um
on dailywire.com and uh if you go to
dailywire.com shop you can go and you
can find all the all the hosts we have
our own merchandise but what you want to
do is skip by all the other hosts and go
right to my page and i have to say yeah
i was looking at some of those
merchandise last night and i i think
i know i'm biased but i think we have
some great merchandise we'll put a
some images up on the screen here but
we have some real i am jealous of my own
merchants i want all of this merchandise
for myself i think it's really good
we've got um we've got a couple
different skews of the the sweet baby
gang t-shirt now so if you're one of
those people who feels weird about
wearing
you know a shirt with a picture of a
bearded guy with a with a diaper
if you're you know
if that's how you feel
if you're a little discriminatory like
that that we do have a sweet baby
getting shirt that doesn't have um
doesn't have the diaper
we've got a return or die
shirt with a picture of a shopping cart
that probably is my favorite
we've got some anti-panda related gear
which is which is really good uh save a
boiler we got to save a boiler shirt so
a lot of great stuff there make sure to
go
shop go to the matt wall store
and uh this is the time to do it right
before christmas
this is what and i'm not and i don't say
this as a joke or ironically this is
what everyone in my family is gonna be
getting
all right
assuming i can get the merchandise for
free which is still not
i'm still not totally sure about
at least maybe i'll get a five percent
discount or something okay this is from
andrew says matt i am getting relentless
criticism from from my incorrect peers
for my belief that arby's is much better
than in and out and burger king
i know what your belief of arby's is so
i'd like to ask what is your message to
all my friends who truly believe that
burger king and in-n-out are superior to
arby's
um yeah these are people who've you know
they
kind of kind of standard going with the
flow going with the crowd
allowing themselves to be influenced by
peer pressure
in and out is nothing impressive at all
burger king
um
i've never been to a burger king that
was better than subpar like like subpar
is the best you can hope for when it
comes to burger king
the thing is you go to burger king
and you you can run into this with all
the with all the fast food places
but anytime you you order a whopper from
burger king
you know you you try to pick it up and
it's the entire thing is scalding hot
including the bun
the mayonnaise is like magma or
something because they throw the entire
thing mayonnaise bun and lettuce and all
into the microwave before they hand it
to you
um
they don't do that with arby's or if
they do you don't notice it
so i'm in agreement with you mike says
totally agree with matt on the
socialization of public school versus
homeschool after my 13 years of public
education i spent at least the next five
years unlearning all the immature
ridiculous behaviors that i picked up
in public school
yeah that's that's exactly right we've
talked before about why why is it that
uh that in fact despite what you hear
public this public school environment is
not a great socialization environment
well the reason is
that um in many public schools anyway
like the one that i went to
you are in a classroom with 30 other
kids
and uh and one teacher and the the
adults and are vastly outnumbered by the
kids
and so you're picking up all of your
social cues from other kids
that's how you're learning how to act in
the world
all of your ideas about etiquette and
and everything and how to behave
you're picking that up from other kids
because you're surrounded by other kids
and you live you you live every day in
this pure culture
this kind of lord of the flies ruthless
peer culture
so in order to survive socially
you learn to blend in and pick up cues
from your
from your
fellow students
and act like they do and meanwhile
they're picking up cues from you so
you're all just chasing each other's
tail you're going in a circle
in homeschooling
um
you know there is
an adult and
far fewer kids and so the kids are
looking to the adult they're picking up
their social cues from the adult their
parent
and i think that's how they end up being
more mature people and oftentimes when
you hear about how homeschoolers are
weird and all of that
what you're really picking up on is that
they're mature
so a weird homeschooler you know 17 year
old homeschooler
you think that that 17 year old is weird
because
he is acting like a young adult as he
should
and you're so used to the 17 year old
hooligans who are emotionally and
psychologically repressed and suppressed
and confused
um
now what else we got here
um
brian says why is a sweet baby gang
t-shirt in xl always sold out do you
recommend that i eat more and moved into
a 2xl or is this a lame attempt to get
gang members to get in better shape so
they can fit in a large well we've got a
lot of big babies in the sweet baby gig
so stop body shaming them well you might
be doing some traveling this holiday i'd
recommend
traveling by car if you can so you can
avoid all the craziness in the airports
but if you're doing that that means that
you gotta you know you're that's the gas
expenses that's when that really comes
in and that's why beforehand get the get
upside app my listeners are making up to
25 cents for every gallon of gas every
time they fill up just download the free
get upside app in the app store or
google play right now use promo code
wall should get a bonus 25 cents on your
first tank that's up to 50 cents cash
back on your first tank 25 cents cash
back uh from there on out don't pay full
price at the pump anymore there's no
reason to do it especially when the
price is as high as it is right now get
cash back using get upside just download
the app for free use promo code walsh to
get up to 50 cents a gallon cashback on
your first tank some people who drive a
lot are making hundreds of dollars a
month i mean two three hundred four
hundred dollars a month and you can cash
out any time it's very easy to do the
money goes to your bank account it goes
to paypal you can even put it into uh
like a gift card whatever you want to do
just download the free get upside app
and use promo code walsh to get up to 50
cents a gallon cash back on your first
tank that's code walsh and
well we just talked about this but i
guess we'll talk about it again the
daily wire store is open daily wire shop
dailywire.com shop
is open right now all of the wonderful
daily wire merchandise is available you
can check it all out there and you know
i talked about my own store but there is
other stuff you could buy as well like
our let's go brandon tailgate gear and
so so much more anyone can shop at the
daily wire store but only daily wire
members will get special discounts up to
20 off members also receive access to
shop exclusive merch like our extremely
special baseball bat which is uh
handcrafted in collaboration with
pillbox bat company and in celebration
of the good old days when cracker jack's
national anthem and take me out to the
ball game were the norm at every ball
game those were the days so head to
dailywire.com shop to get a little
something for everyone on your list who
loves brandon and orr is a member of the
sweet baby gang and if you're not yet a
member if you sign up right now at
dailywire.com subscribe and enter code
dw35 you'll get 35 off your membership
and all the perks you wouldn't otherwise
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
now to be totally honest with you i
wanted to do a big and epic cancellation
today as we head into the thanksgiving
holiday or at least as i head into it
because i won't be here tomorrow but
my plans for a grand and dramatic and
perhaps even historic segment were
derailed when i happened across this new
york post article and found myself once
again highly annoyed by something
relatively trivial the forces of the
universe have now compelled me again to
spend our remaining minutes together
talking about um this instead i can't
help it's not my fault it's this
person's fault as new york post reports
a distraught mom has taken to tick tock
saying that she feels like a failure
after learning her seven-year-old son is
a bully
now we'll pause there for a moment just
to say that um
we are already on the wrong foot anytime
distraught
and taken to tick-tock are in the same
sentence
there are many understandable things a
person might reasonably do when they're
distraught
even some understandable things they
might unreasonably do but making a
tick-tock video is not one of them
no sincere stable person has ever felt
truly distraught and said to themselves
oh no i'm distraught this is terrible
it's tragic i'm devastated wait where's
my phone this will make a great
tick-tock vid
no sincere and stable people don't do
that which means that if you're doing
that you're either insincere or unstable
or both probably both anyway back to the
article it says
the mom named beth posted an emotional
video to the social media site last week
detailing the moment that she learned
her boy had attacked an overweight pier
while on board a school bus
i feel like a failure beth wrote beneath
the clip which has been viewed more than
1.5 million times
my son came home telling me another
parent threatened him for accidentally
knocking his son's glasses off his face
she explained i believed every word that
came out of his mouth
beth decided to speak with the school
bus driver after her son told her the
incident occurred on board the vehicle
and she was stunned by what she found
out next
quote the driver explained to me how
this child is heavyset and he can't get
off the bus quickly he told me how my
child was shoving this boy down the
aisle because he wasn't fast enough
my child ripped the boy's glasses off
his face and threw them to the back of
the bus
it's not funny um
it's not funny bullying is not funny
beth said that she was left heartbroken
after learning of the incident and it
really hit home as she herself had been
bullied about her weight when she was a
child
okay now in fairness to her son
you really should move faster when
you're getting off the school bus nobody
wants to be on that thing any longer
than they need to be
and i'm not sure how being heavyset is
an excuse here frankly i'm not condoning
what her son did especially because
there's a distinct possibility that this
woman is mentally ill and none of this
really happened
she might not even have a son
the story sounds
fabricated
her son if she has one is acting like
the stereotypical bully from like a 90s
nickelodeon cartoon hey get out of my
way four eyes
i'm surprised he didn't give the kid a
wedgie and then peer pressure him into
smoking a cigarette out behind the
bleachers or something but assuming this
really did happen uh we'll continue the
post says
beth said she was left heartbroken after
learning of the incident and it really
hit home as she herself had been bullied
about her way when she was a child i do
not condone this behavior and it's not
tolerated the mom said as she sobbed on
screen i don't know where to go from
here i'm obviously doing something wrong
the emotional parent confessed
well i've got some ideas beth
about what you might be doing wrong but
before i share those with you let's take
a look at one of the viral tick tock
videos she made stemming from this
potentially fictional incident
um here's one where she addressed the
bully the bull she addresses the bullied
child directly in this video and lip
syncs an inspirational song to him while
weeping
you're not going to be able to
appreciate the sheer cringe of this
video unless you unless you see the
actual visuals so if you're listening to
the audio make sure to go over to
youtube or something to watch this
because you have to see it
uh here it is
[Music]
i promise you're enough
[Music]
[Music]
do these people not have anyone in their
life
to stop them from doing this
do they not have anyone to say no this
is don't don't this the cringe here is
too much
that is a tough one to get through not
because it's emotionally affecting but
because of the nuclear-grade second-hand
embarrassment meanwhile she's totally
throwing your own seven-year-old son
under the bus on social media in front
of the entire world again assuming your
seven-year-old son exists
this is the real cancel offense
obviously if you find out that your
child has bullied another another child
you should dole out the appropriate
correction and discipline
you should handle the situation as a
parent but what you don't need to do and
should not do and shouldn't ever even
think about doing
is broadcast the situation on social
media
you shouldn't get the public involved in
your relatively routine parenting
situation
parenting is not a spectator sport your
child is not a public figure
you don't need to issue statements and
press releases if he gets in trouble at
school
you keep it private
if you feel the need to reach out to a
child that your bratty kid is bullied
reach out to him go to the bus stop and
talk to him call his parents whatever
you don't need to connect with him via
tick tock video he's seven
he shouldn't even know what tick-tock is
and if he does he's got bigger problems
than a little scuffle on the school bus
this is a pretty widespread problem
these days parents who essentially use
their own children
as click bait
exploiting them for shares and likes
and it's not even clear to what end i
mean unless you make a living as a
content creator why do you care about
getting shares and going viral what good
does it do you
how do you benefit
well i suppose it satisfies the need
that satisfies the need for attention a
need that has grown ever stronger in the
human species more insatiable as our
lives are increasingly consumed by the
internet attention is the currency of
the internet it's the original
cryptocurrency
and some people many people are so
desperate to be rich in that kind of
bitcoin that they'll think nothing of
selling out their own children
anything for a small ration a small
taste of attention
anything for approval and affirmation
from faceless strangers who don't know
you or care about you and won't remember
your content 15 seconds from now
and that is why this woman whatever her
name is because i've already forgotten
which proves my point
is canceled
that'll do it for us today and the week
have a great thanksgiving
and i will talk to you next week
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadosky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2021.
criminal justice reform leaves five
people dead and 48 injured in wisconsin
the gop peddles a radical transgender
bill and mostly peaceful looters empty
out three stores in san francisco check
it out on the michael knowles show